To plug it into it.
I forget how you make copies.
Uh,
the same way you'd put your original would be like on the left tend to feed.
You did,
you'd need a copier.
You couldn't do it with this machine.
Probably the same way people did was VCR copies back in the early eighties.
Know tape to tape.
You'd fix it.
The same thing,
how it would degrade
you get foreigns from your friend.
And it was like,
like someone threw mud in your eyes when he tried to watch it.
The fuck is happening on the screen because it was so many generations of
copied.
Do you remember when porn was watching like this?
I don't remember it,
but I heard about it and I remember,
um,
that movie about the dude from Hogan's heroes that was a,
uh,
he,
he was on hook and heroes and after Hogan's heroes,
he just went around making his own homemade porn
and he,
you know,
he had one of these kinds of things when the home projector type deals,
porn came [inaudible] those days if you went to the back of a dirty magazine,
not playboy and not penthouse,
but anything else,
they would actually send you a projector with three movies for say 1495.
There was a lull in projected,
probably going to work 10 times,
but at least you've got to watch porn and they'd send you a reel to reel.
That was so bad.
Porn was so bad.
And I still remember a story with me and my friends chipping in and getting the
fucking reel to reel with the thing and plugging it into the wall and put the
sheets on the windows.
And it was just horrible,
horrible born white chicks.
They would find it off the streets.
Flapjack titties,
somebody turns cigarettes off on the chest.
And this chick was half on drugs and she had to suck the guy's Dick and the most
vivid picture I members when she took the mayonnaise with the bread,
like she was sucking this guy's Dick.
The guy's Dick had been beat up and she took mayonnaise.
Miracle Whip.
That's why I never liked miracle whip.
She put it on the bread and made a Dick Sandwich was dick and it was like me and
three other 12 year olds dog.
We almost had a heart attack.
You understand me?
Like our heads blew up.
I turn it off,
turn it off,
turn it off.
Who wants this fucking projector?
No,
no,
no.
It was a cheap,
cheap,
cheap little projector.
You had to put a sheet up on the wall and use it as a screen.
Yeah,
the fucking shade up all your windows in the attic.
Because I used to do it in my attic because my mother wasn't home,
so I was the first viewing party we had was in my attic.
You had to send the money order and yeah,
they said the dollar might 95 for shipping and handling.
That's an h and then it would take six weeks to delivery,
so you would just sit and you couldn't send it to your house.
So I would have to send it to Rogan's house because I knew his mother and his
grandmother workload back so they'd never be home.
So they would just drop the package off in front of the house.
If one of our mothers found that package,
we'd be dead.
We'd be fucking dead.
Can you imagine your mother check mic?
It's miracle whip on a piece of bread and eats into the fucking get deck with
thought.
He think moms today probably wouldn't even flinch.
What if,
what if they found their kid with something like that on his companion are
fucking kidding me.
Every mom the edit.
You talked to any mom or a 15 year old and go,
do you think your son's getting late?
She's like,
stop it.
I don't want to hear that.
It's true.
No mom wants to hear that.
Sudden getting laid.
The first girl you brought over the house actually bothered your mother.
Oh I'm sure the first two girls you brought home actually bothered and irritated
the shit out of your mother.
It took your mom a while because you're always going to be that little boy.
I can't imagine him getting his dick sucked.
He just,
I just put diapers on 10 years ago.
You know what else they worry about?
They worry about you getting somebody pregnant cause you're so stupid when
you're 15 1617 you guys are just doing stupid shit.
You know,
you don't really know how to pull out that good.
How good are our yet that he's not very good.
You know when you're that young,
I mean it's,
your parents are worried about you doing something dumb.
Your parents are worried about yeah,
getting pregnant but they also don't want you to having sec.
I had the skinny girl friend,
like I always had girls that were friends and after the girls would leave,
my mind would pull me aside and said what's going on?
And I go,
nothing.
You know,
she's just a friend and I would have steam out of the house.
I can't believe it,
you know,
and they were friends,
but that was just one skinny girl.
But I used to bring her over in the seventh grade and my mother caught us one
afternoon.
She called us making it happen.
So she asked me as a man,
she goes from now on,
do me a fucking favor.
She's hearing,
I'm downstairs.
Just leave the door.
My mom was one of those dog,
she was one of those,
just do me a favor just from the Middle East when I leave and lock the door.
But if I'm hearing,
just leave the door open and I would leave it open the foot and then try to
eight inches,
six inches,
and she would have to come up and say,
Oh,
something 20 what did I tell you?
Leave the fucking door open.
And then you,
you're an animal like that age.
So at that age you from,
are we talking mental him?
Because all I was doing was dry humping this girl.
That's all I was doing.
We weren't having sex.
I think I suck the Ted to one time,
you know,
we weren't having sex,
it was just making out and dry humping.
But one day I had died,
my mom had to Barstow and she would just fucking come home and they have to lose
to see if I was at this broad and one dad in here and she brought one of her
friends up.
One of her friends,
I'm just swap and split with the chip,
but I hear something on the wall like something's going on.
But I kept dry humping that we had earth,
wind and fire arrows can I love great fucking out off.
That's the way of the world.
I'm driving up and this checked that that the Olson,
I hear a lot of slip and the guy starts yelling,
ahh.
And I ran downstairs and it was my,
one of my mother's friends are Nardo.
He used to be a bookie at my mother's Blah.
So my mother goes,
I got to get to the bottom of this.
I got to know what this kid's gonna lace.
So he volunteers,
but the ladder at the side of the house
to see if I'm getting laid to look in the window.
God,
I had an air conditioner with a curtain.
He could never see it anyway,
but this girl pissed off.
My mom feels this went on for about a year and then I started taking my shirt
off and suck in a tense and my dad came home one day and caught him in the
closet and that was the end.
And then my mom would give me shit for a little while.
I got to be 1213 I'm in the sixth grade.
Me and this girl would watch the Osmond's on Friday and Saturday,
Donny and Marie and I would get pissed off because she had a crush.
I'm fucking Donny,
you know,
you're a kid.
And then when they in,
but then we figured out,
fuck if they're gonna Watch this after three why don't we play Hooky from 12 to
three we could dry out for three hours and nobody will know your grandmother
works.
My mother is definitely not coming home.
So we used to play hooky and I'm one day they caught us and her and I had like,
there was 20 feet between us and offense that parents had a house right behind
mine.
And my mom went into the back yard like the fucking Spanish from when that she
is and started yelling at me,
what is a whore
over here every day?
I don't know what they do in that room.
I hope she's not sucking his deck.
Oh my God.
It was just a,
my son was a regular little boy until your daughter took over.
And I know I used to walk her home and I remember walking into the house and the
mom was like,
can I talked to me for a second?
Your mom's out there yelling horrible things about my daughter calling her
orange.
Wow.
I had to go home and tell my Mama what's up with that.
She's a fucking whore for the job.
My mom could I warm and drama and that's what I got a girlfriend.
No more problems after that.
It was just this skinny chick that drove my mother fucking crazy.